it's pretty fantastic this is huge for
me
life is good for John Krasinski the
actor recently added another notch on
his directing belt with his new
comedy-drama the haulers out August 26
it's a narrative film it's got a whole
new level of responsibility which is you
know if you're not moving people your
family on a personal note things
couldn't be better
John attended the New York City premiere
of his new film Thursday alongside wife
Emily Blunt who looked incredible just
weeks after giving birth to their second
daughter violet
even I have to work way too hard to look
even like this and she just does it by
waking up so John couldn't help but gush
over his family praising his oldest
daughter hazel for being so sweet with
her newborn sister she really loves the
baby and I think that there's this idea
of oh my god she's adorable and I mean
when when a two-and-a-half-year-old hugs
a newborn baby it's one of the cutest
things older sis and when it comes to
being a dad John says it's completely
transformed his life all the cliches of
parenting or true and you feel all sorts
of new things it was really this new
existential magnet that you feel draw to
your family and it just was very much
more weighty than I expected it to be so
I was probably working a whole lot out
in this movie
you